[Music]
this is star talk in a things you
thought you knew edition
and i can't do that without chuck knight
chuck hey neil with me with me on this
yeah yeah whatever these are so much fun
and i got a segment here it's on the
space time continuum all right that's
i'm i'm cool with that you've heard that
and you've heard that you're kidding me
it is only
the premise of every freaking sci-fi
thing ever yes yes i just want to go i
don't want to ground it travel i just
want to ground it in a few ways that i
don't think people spend time doing
so let's let's think this are you going
to ruin space time the week no no
is that what's going to happen right now
nothing i can do can help pluto just so
you know
it's out of my hands
so
i've washed my hands of its demolition
you are the pontius pilate
yeah that's a line right out of
so one of those accounts
of the trial of jesus
so
so here we go
1905
you should know immediately one thing
should know in your head 1905. einstein
comes out with this special theory of
relativity right okay that's right this
is on fire
it's not what he called it it was the
paper that delivered it to us is called
on the electrodynamics of moving bodies
and no one wanted to recite that so just
called special relativity but that's
what it is because it's all about
the relativity of motion and time okay
so
what it did was codify
the fact
that
that spatial dimensions
need a for the three spatial dimensions
you know height width and depth need a
fourth dimension
to localize it in any
spatial system you're talking about
and since you needed time then it's a
space-time system
so
so
it sounds like it's weird like what are
you doing einstein you know leave me
alone with my height with and depth but
it turns out we have always thought
about life in four dimensions
always
and here's an example of why
if i say to you chuck
i'll meet you tomorrow morning at 10
o'clock
i'll say great what are we doing i'm so
excited to find out okay i love when you
surprised me like this well okay okay i
can do that but i'll say all right
that's fine i'll meet you at the corner
of
5th avenue and 34th street
okay
what's your next question to me and when
cause i don't want to stay there all day
waiting for you so you knew that giving
you those coordinates right earth
surface 33rd street
fifth avenue 34th street you knew
that's insufficient for us to actually
meet absolutely you're going to say when
bada bing the time coordinate just got
slapped on there did you just bother
bing space-time
i did i did bada-bing space-time all
right awesome
uh you know is that is that forgivable
to you yeah i think yeah
all right so and you can reverse that
right i can say
uh chuck i'll meet you at 12 noon
tomorrow
okay and your next question to me is
when or where i just said when okay
where where exactly so we cannot meet
unless
the spatial coordinate is specified and
the temporal coordinate is specified oh
and by the way because we're all kind of
stuck on earth's surface if you want to
do the full up three-dimensional meet in
space i would say i'll meet you at 50 at
fifth avenue 34th street 107 floors up
okay or 86 floors up that would be the
empire state building because that's the
coordinate of the empire state building
so i give one dimension the other
dimension and then a height dimension
those are all three dimensions
often you don't give the height
dimension because you're just meeting on
the street all right it's just implicit
yes we're going to meet on earth surface
this time
right right that one is an easy one to
just accept as a given but technically
if you wanted all three
if you wanted to do it full up you give
three dimensions earth's surface
34th street fifth avenue and
at a time so we already knew this
but no one thought about it that way
now here are the consequences of that if
you're crossing the street
and then a minute later a truck
go drives down the street
for you were in the same place as that
truck
right when you were in the middle of the
street at the right time though
i was in that same place
i mean the right time meaning that's not
where the truck is at that time exactly
yeah so i'd want to say you were in the
same place at the wrong time you're at
the same place at the right time right
so so off we are always in the same
place as each other but it doesn't mean
anything until you're there at the same
time
so i just want to drive home that
concept so now let's go to sci-fi movies
uh how about back to the future one of
the greatest sort of
thought through time travel stories
there are uh including the terminator i
think thought through time travel very
hard yeah they did all right yeah i have
an issue wait i have an issue um
with with arnold um
why do you have a problem so on the
first the first
i'll tell you dude that he goes back in
time to
kill
uh the the possible parents of
john the leader of the of the new uh
movement of the resistance but all he
had to do
is
prevent
his
the parents from meeting each other i
mean you can go back four generations
earlier and just put two people on a
different train so they never meet and
that entire genetic lineage never exists
right so this idea that he's got to kill
them and it's gonna be all bloody that
made it like a violent movie but it
could have been done a little more
with less blood and gore but also just
the fact that when he comes through he
comes out butt naked remember that
in this bubble and you remember why i
had to come through butt naked uh
because i am flesh over endoskeleton
no because nothing no living tissue no
dead tissue made it through this go
through right it could go through the
time machine
except of course
hair is dead
so he would have been just totally bald
coming to end no eyebrows no nothing
okay i just thought i'd say that that
there was an inconsistencies
it's giving me alopecia
what happened
alopecia
how do you even know that that exists
alopecia is where you don't you lose all
your hair you know grow your hair at any
age it can happen anyways no matter what
alopecia all right so uh where was i oh
so here's what you have to be concerned
about let's go to back to the future
when uh marty yeah give me some doc
brown here
marty it's it's time
no now i'm in the mood thank you
all right get the call marty
so
so there's marty and he's being chased
by the libyan terrorists okay that's
right that's right
and
in the parking lot in the twin pines
parking lot all right and then he he he
there's a date in there from 1955 and he
goes back in time
to 1955.
okay and he lands in the twin pines
ranch because as we know all good
farmland becomes strip malls right in
modern times all right
okay
what they didn't address
is the fact that he would only land in
that ranch
if
he goes back to when
earth was in the same place in its orbit
he would have to be traveling on the
anniversary of the date that he was that
of when he left
so that earth is back where it is so
that when he goes back in time he
doesn't end up suffocating in the vacuum
of space
oh man that
first of all would be the best time
travel short film ever
i discovered the secrets of time travel
right get in the car and then the tumor
just float in his face
the end to the end
i didn't think this through money
[Laughter]
so you need so so i'm just saying it's
not good enough just to travel back in
time you need something to propel you in
space as well so it's a space time a
space time machine
not just a time machine because earth is
a moving target
i just want to make that clear that's
really cool actually and by the way just
to go back in time you could still land
on earth but how was earth rotated you
could end up in siberia in the middle of
the ocean probably because most of earth
longitude is spanned by ocean um so
so i i just want to sort of it's truth
in time travel with regard to these
space-time coordinates now um we call
these
your coordinate in space and your
coordinated time we call that your world
line
really yes that's a cool term
worldwide
so your word line is where and when you
are
live so you can step back and look at
everyone's world lines and the world
lines are sort of it's think of it as
some kind of shadow moving
through this hyper coordinate system and
so that way if i have to go to even a
higher dimension so i can see your
entire world line if i see your entire
world line you are always being born
you're always living out your life and
you're always dying right because i can
see the time
right the whole timeline is there in
front of me right and i can see other
people's world lines intersect your
world line oh that's when you met your
wife okay that's when you were in my
office and we recorded that episode so
so imagine this spaghetti picture
of all these world lines of human beings
interacting this is cool
and that i don't think i don't know that
anyone has actually thought to portray
that no they have not that's why i said
this is so cool because first of all
first i've ever heard of it but secondly
that is something that nobody's put in
sci-fi in terms of actually i take it
back there there's a couple
star trek episodes where they play with
that but they don't present it that way
they still present the linear
uh as portrayed in different positions
exactly and so the linear and different
but what you're talking about is so much
cooler actually what you're talking
about is um on a religious from a
religious standpoint what people believe
to be
god's way of seeing time and space which
makes everything predetermined yet still
gives us
responsibility for our actions that
right it's it's how that all plays out
thank you reverend chuck
it's a new the church the new church of
world lines is the new church world live
the space time continuum all right so
anyhow so that's that's how that works
and one last point in
kurt vonnegut's novel slaughterhouse
five which ostensibly takes place in at
the end of the second world war um and
there's the other sort of historical
details i won't get into what i was most
intrigued by is the time travel that
goes on in that and he actually captures
that accurately so what happens is the
lead protagonist gets abducted by aliens
gets put in a cage and that sounds bad
but they said no you're still there
you're still being born you're still
dying and they went outside of his
timeline and so he would sit there and
daydream but by daydreaming he was
living his life and he could relive his
life multiple ways and in multiple times
wait just real quick because we're
running out of time dr manhattan i
forgot also is the is a character who
lives in his world line and also sees
his world line simultaneously okay this
is uh of the uh dr manhattan from
uh the watchman watson correct yes yes
yes excellent yeah he's that's a pretty
powerful guy yeah i mean once you have
him what why have anything do anything
you know that's what i don't like that's
why i don't like watchmen believe it or
not for what you just said because it's
like i got dr manhattan i mean i'm done
here my answer to everything is like
seriously bro
i've got dr manhatt yeah that's the
answer dr manhattan it's dr manhattan
it's over the whole thing so now one
other quick thing all right um
if you have an ant in a in a square
okay
and let's say there's a sticky edge on
the square that's basically a prison for
the ant you could tell me an ant just go
up an inch and out and over no but the
ant is stuck in two dimensions
the two dimensions of the paper that's
at a length and a and a width okay or
height or whatever
those two dimensions the ant is stuck
if he had access to the if it had access
to a third dimension it could escape the
prison right because the confined height
and escape right so think about it
if you are in an actual jail cell
and you had access to a fourth dimension
a fourth spatial dimension you just have
to step out of the spatial into the
spatial dimension and step back in and
you just walk out of the prison without
ever
touching the walls
okay so that's how you escape prison
just invent a fourth spatial dimension
to do that so then i thought if you need
a spatial dimension for that then what
about our fourth time dimension
why can't we why can't that work for us
the way a fourth spatial dimension it
does
it does here it is you ready so somebody
put you in jail and now you enter your
fourth time dimension you go to it
return to your time dimension
before you were put in prison
right now you're not in prison you just
escape the prison and you do it or after
you escape
so that it works the same way as the
spatial dimension if we can invent that
but i'm just
that
that's all i got to say about that yeah
a better thing would do would be to
return to
before you committed the crime and not
committed
chuck
the moral of the
the moralist reverend chuck
all right all right chuck we're out of
time in fact we went a little over on
this segment because there was some such
juicy stuff in the space-time continuum
but when we come back we'll pick up on
stuff you thought you know
and we'll talk about the moon
on star talk
chuck yes i'm excited about this one i'm
going to talk about the moon okay
all right now there's a lot of these
where we talk about the moon but i want
to put it all in one place at one time
here and now all right that sounds good
all right all right
exist
every
moon joke yeah every every mooning
jupiter i am yes um right now i'm just
putting myself in the mental space
to stop thinking about butts
and cracks and all of that all of that
all right here we go all right so this
is mostly moon lore i just want to put
it all under one
on the one roof okay oh i love it so
let's start out with the moon on horizon
illusion you ever hear about that
the moon on the horizon no i don't know
so what it is it's what we call it maybe
you you felt it you see the moon rising
over the city landscape or the mountain
of course and it's huge yes it's so
beautiful it's beautiful big giant
yellow ball ball right right and you
don't have that reaction when it's up
overhead no because it's a little yellow
dot and okay that's not empty so so why
does the moon
feel bigger on the horizon than high in
the sky it is it is not actually bigger
at all okay you can measure it in fact
it's slightly smaller for other reasons
i'm not going to get into but
it so it's completely psychological and
so we call it the moon on horizon
illusion
nice yeah because your brain
makes a judgment at all times how far
away something is uh-huh it's making
this judgment okay stereopsis
based on that that's yeah correct and
based on that judgment
it will say here's how i big i think
that object is
right so think about it if you if you
look at i'm gonna have a really stupid
obvious example
if you look up in the sky and you see an
airplane
you're not saying to yourself oh the
airplane's only this big it can fit
between my fingers you you're not saying
that
but you do take your fingers and hold it
up and look make it look like you're
flying the airplane like you know yeah
i've never done that check yeah okay
good all right i'm sorry moving on
sorry i've never done that
so maybe others have i don't know i just
personally
i don't believe i have to help the
airplane through this guy
and and and i felt that way very early
in my life
so so you you know
not only intuitively but your brain is
doing
subliminal calculations about how big
something would actually be
if it were right in front of you
for how small it is for how far away you
see it
to be all right so it makes sense the
moon as far as your depth perception is
concerned is basically at infinity
okay it's basically at infinity that
makes sense so what happens is
the moon shows up
in the company of terrestrial objects
you are familiar with
buildings mountains trees
you know how big those are
okay fascinating and then the moon is
hanging out with them
and so your brain is like wait a minute
is that is it really there or is that it
no but
and
while your brain is trying to figure
this out your brain starts thinking the
moon is huge huger than at any other
time in the sky
and by the way you said the moon is
yellow you know why it's yellow when
it's low on the horizon
uh i
i mean i can only guess that it's
atmospheric yeah exactly it's for the
same reason the sun is yellow on the
horizon the sun isn't actually yellow
it's yellow on the horizon because the
atmosphere is affecting the color and if
you have a polluted sky it'll be deeper
and deeper deeper from yellow into amber
and maybe even red so you can get very
sort of deep deep
deep amber moon if it stays low point is
this is a moon on horizon illusion and
people say i saw such a big moon last
night i'm saying no you didn't you only
thought it was big wow
that is
so cool by the way so now last point
about the moon on the horizon okay
what's throwing off your depth cues
is the full moon mixed in with other
things that are familiar to you as
i've already said correct okay if you
have the full moon rising
over
a horizon for which you have no depth
cues
the effect is greatly diminished and in
fact it's hardly there at all
for example the moon rising at sea i was
gonna say it on the over the ocean over
the open ocean there's no trees there's
no buildings there's nothing
so that that effect is greatly
diminished and you want to know how to
get rid of the effect entirely
here's what you do there's the large
moon on the horizon next to buildings
and things
turn around
okay
all right with your back to the moon
okay
bend over
and look at the moon
upside down through your legs
okay okay okay
okay now don't pull down your drawers
when you're doing this because then
you'll be mooning the moon okay
but
if you do this
then the building's on the horizon and
the trees are upside down
and your brain says i don't know what
that is
i don't want to upside down i don't know
what that is oh so now i can put the
moon where it belongs at infinity and
the moon becomes its regular size
so the lack of reference causes your
brain to see the moon
the way it is instead of
causing it to make the association to
the size of the things surrounding it
correct correct and so
so so and and i invite you to do that
experiment next time the moon looks
suspiciously large on the horizon just
bend over
it goes right back to its eyes you get
two bada bings and one and yes you can
what are you doing well i'm looking at
the moon and kissing my ass goodbye
all right so more about the moon the
moon is always opposite the full moon is
talking about the full moon here it's
always opposite the sun
all right that's because that's why it's
full it's it's full frontal to the sun
it's getting the full reflection of the
sun the full refrigerant from from our
point of view on earth okay so
uh
because you mentioned the moon is kind
of yellowish on the horizon yellowish
amber and i might have said this at
another time but here's a good place to
reinsert it
all right
uh in the summertime
uh the sun
it takes this very high arc across the
sky
okay
and then when the sun sets
it takes a very low arc beneath the
horizon because it doesn't stay down
there very long well if it takes a low
arc on the horizon if you have full moon
the full moon we will be opposite it and
we'll also be in a low arc
okay so now watch so watch in the summer
time like in june you know right
june when the full moon rises
it stays low in the sky
really low doesn't get very high at all
so if you if you had sort of sunset
colors on the moon right when it rose
and it doesn't get very high
it's never going to
free itself of the contaminating effects
the color contamination of the sky of
the of our atmosphere
so it'll it'll it'll come up it'll be
like deep amber but it's not gonna
really ever not be amber in that very
low arc across the sky and then it sets
all right
wait a minute the full moon in june
stays low on the sky and it's in it and
it holds on to those sort of sunset
amber colors
it takes on a kind of a honey color
oh
of all the moons of the year and they
all have names the name of the full moon
in june
is the honeymoon the honeymoon
what
bada bing that's sweet
i feel like i should be
doing something more with the moon
so i just wanted to bada bing the moon
is that allowed how many bangs in the
day do i get i don't know i don't know
if you get the bada bing the moon
especially on the honeymoon
honeymoon so every moon has a has every
full moon has a name you've heard of
some of the harvest moon this sort of
thing flowers
yeah the flower and they're all cultural
and regional by the way depending on
what mattered there's a wolf moon a snow
moon this sort of thing so the blue moon
is my favorite no don't don't go there
please don't come on man why not no
that's a whole other explainer no no
just that's a different explainer video
to back away from the term
put the term down on the table right and
step away
[Laughter]
all right all right maybe i should
should i slip it in here all right let
me slip it out we might run out of time
i don't know okay all right uh do you
know what the blood moon is i i've heard
of it i don't know what it is well
you're like how are you talking about it
you don't know what it is dude because
it's my favorite term for the moon the
blue okay so this is the term that some
people invented
to describe the full moon during a lunar
eclipse yes
that's where i heard it okay so so a
blood moon could then happen at any time
of the year if there is a lunar eclipse
okay and what happens in a lunar eclipse
earth
interposes itself
between the sun and the moon
okay
so exactly interposes itself in such a
way that it's like the moon is like yo
hold me back hold me back
and the sun is like you better hold him
back
cause i'm about to mess him up bad he's
like ladies and gentlemen chuck is from
philadelphia
and the earth is like guys guys come on
seriously guys
that's always what the person who's
stopping the fight sounds like why why
is the person stopping the fight oh wait
guys guys come on guys come on guys
seriously it's never stop the fight
right no the person who sounds like that
never stops fights they start him
all right so watch what happens so we
are in space
earth isn't people say i want to go into
space just stand on earth you're in
space all right so earth is in space and
there's a shadow that's always there
cast by the sun
okay now you have the moon orbiting the
earth and occasionally the moon will
enter that shadow
blocking the light of the sun from the
fully illuminated moon and we have a
lunar eclipse
a lunar eclipse okay
so if you were to watch this from the
moon
you'll see this dark orb
move slowly and begin to blot out the
sun okay
the earth is much bigger than the sun on
the sky
all right so it is it the sun is lost
behind the earth again let's watch this
from the moon now okay so now here's
what happens
sunlight
tries to get around to the other side
by working its way through earth's
atmosphere
right okay so the light sort of
disperses and and refracts a little
almost like a filter or yeah
but it's only around the edges because
the full disc of the sun is blocked by
the moon by the right so it's just light
that's trying to work its way around if
you have a heavy heavily polluted
atmosphere okay then that sunlight gets
deeply reddened as you would have a deep
red
sun on our settings at sunset right
on the horizon just like it would be on
the horizon okay just like it would be
because the sun technically is on the
horizon for that picture all right so if
you have a highly polluted or it's over
the sahara where there's a lot of dust
particles kicked up then it deeply
reddens the sunlight that leaks around
the earth
and some of that spills into earth's
shadow
and so the moon which would otherwise be
completely blotted out
can take on
a very deep sort of amber look a ruddy
ready ready but okay that can happen
i saw it happen several times in the
1960s and early 70s and i have not seen
that happen since
we've been cleaning up the air of the
earth
because what makes the sun deeply red
people say oh it's beautiful look no
because air got particles in it okay
you're breathing pollutants you're
breathing particulates all right so
that's what's reddening the sun you have
less of that the sun is less red in a
lunar eclipse i've not seen a red moon
lunar eclipse in 40 years oh
but they say blood red and plus it's not
red it's like a deep amber all right
it's not any more red than someone who
has red hair you is it is it actually
red no it's more it's it's just rusted
color hold it up to a red is it that red
no
no okay right a little ginger kid you
yeah so what happens is people
exaggerate the color of other people
right all right and so when they when
they're being described white people
aren't purely white black people aren't
purely black and we have a word for how
much light you reflect is called albedo
by the way
albedo so albedo of one means you
reflect all the light albedo of zero
means you absorb all the light but
anyway that's that's another explainer
we'll get to that joe so
here's my point so that's how you would
get a red moon
and people want to say blood so i've
seen people who are very taken by
vocabulary by word a blood red moon that
means something bad is going to happen
just because somebody misnamed it
doesn't mean you now have get to take
the word and create a whole
system
of cultism around the word that someone
badly chose to describe an object in the
sky well thank you for making me hate
blood moons now
it went from my favorite
to the worst i'm just saying so what
will happen is the moon gets eclipsed
and just basically disappears from the
sky in fact most people who have ever
witnessed a lunar eclipse didn't even
know because it looks like uh you have a
crescent moon the earth's shadow is
curved and it just looks like a crescent
moon and it gets a little dimmer and
then it just disappears completely and
then you don't even notice it until it
sort of re-emerges on the other side so
the
a lunar eclipse is long and boring and
hardly noticed by anybody who isn't
looking for it
it's just a reality check don't shoot
the messenger all right last point and
it speaks so highly of you no all right
that's all the time for that segment but
when we come back
we're going to talk about the sun
stuff you thought your son or my son
we both have sons neil
the son oh
the sun they'll get all homonymic on me
here all right we'll be right back
chuck we're back
we talked about space time and we talked
about the moon right we can't talk about
the moon without talking about
the sun the sun so let's get some sun
action here gotta like the sun you gotta
you gotta like the sun let me see the
source of all life on earth almost all
life not all life but mostly yeah
there's some life at the bottom of the
ocean right that never gets that never
even sees the sun i wonder what that's
like it lives where the sun don't shine
[Laughter]
that's funny
yeah yeah in the in the water where the
sun don't shine
so
you know that has me wondering
what happens if you're just a fish
swimming in the water
and then someone captures you
pulls you out of the water into the air
and then there's like land and mountains
and sky and clouds and and direct
sunlight
that's that's that's the closest thing i
can think of to someone grabbing you out
of your dimension and putting you
somewhere else
right but here's what's worse they pull
you out but then they put you back in
the water
right and now you're going around all
the other fish like yo man i'm serious
this really happened to me this happened
to me man okay
like first i thought it was some food
right they grabbed my jaw it wouldn't
let me go i fought and i fought they
pulled me out man i couldn't breathe i
couldn't breathe man and then it was
like all this light i don't even know
what to call it hurt it hurt like hell
man
and it was these things the fleshy
things man and it
was crazy and there was like like you
know what you know what the bottom what
we see down the bottom except instead of
sand it was like sam but it was real
hard and and it was like puffy stuff
above the sand and it was oh man uh why
y'all dude i'm not crazy
yes you are
[Laughter]
you know we're gonna do we're gonna get
someone to animate that that have an
actual fish speaking those words all
right
[Laughter]
so eddie yeah so one of the things they
get to really experience is the sun and
particularly if they live sort of if
they're bottom feeders right the sun is
not a big part of their life really
so so let me talk about the sun the sun
is
uh you know how far away it is in light
travel time
um eight and something minutes yeah good
good yeah you chuck you know you're
coming along here
so it takes 500 seconds for the light to
reach
earth from the sun so 500 seconds if you
do the math it's 8 minutes and 20
seconds all right and it's moving at the
speed of light through the vacuum of
space so that's that's kind of cool and
but you know something earth's
gravitational influence
also moves at that speed
so if some giant came along and plucked
the sun from the center of our solar
system
we would continue to see the sun
feel the sun
orbit the sun
until 8 minutes and 20 seconds passes oh
and then the party is over over that's
all she wrote like you ain't never seen
a party end
and so what then happens is the planets
one by one will fling off into
interstellar space and plunge into
eternal darkness that is a needle
scratch if i ever heard one
and so we need a we need a sci-fi story
where somebody just reaches in and
plucks the sun out and just watches what
happened and and how we are in our
blissful ignorance for eight minutes and
20 seconds you know what that's another
great short film
it's like you know it you show that and
then you show like
the beauty of life in real time of eight
minutes and 20 seconds
and only you the viewer knows that
that's that's all over for everybody to
end and by the way they can't know that
any sooner than when it's too late
because that's that's the rate at which
the information is coming yeah yeah
that's creepy i love it i love it
all right so the sun i just little
tidbits about the sun so maybe it might
not be something you thought you knew
but it might be something you glad you
learned how about that oh wow okay all
right so
if you
hollowed out the sun
so now you just have the volume of the
sun and then i sort of played a little
basketball and started tossing earths
into the sun do you know how many earths
would fit in the sun
oh yeah
i know the sun is huge
compared to the huge huge i don't know
how many earths would fit so take a
guess how many like 10 100 1 000 i will
say thousand or give me a number more
than a thousand earths i'm trying to i'm
looking at the scale models of all the
and uh the things that i've seen okay
on the ceiling of your kids who did the
planet projects
you know
i'm going to say
i'm going to say a hundred thousand
earths okay that's a lot of earths right
i mean a hundred thousand earth so the
actual number the actual number is about
a million what
yes
it's about a million earths
damn a million and so the weird thing is
you go back in time before we had any
sense of anything and there are people
thinking that the sun is just something
else in the sky but earth is the earth
is the earth is the thing right we are
the center right
and since earth and the moon are the
same size on the sky
earth and the moon had almost equal
presence in our culture
right there's a moon god and a sun god
of course every you know that there it
was and any illustrations of the two of
them they're the same size because that
they look that way but they're nowhere
commensurate with each other and it
wasn't until much later that anybody
figured out that the moon does not give
its own light
it is only reflected sunlight
only so there's a geometry of things
going on there but some of that comes
from the bible where i forgot which
passage but it's and the sun it's in
genesis of course and god created the
sun to light the day and the moon to
light the night as though they are their
own agencies of of light sources but
that's that's not the case plus the moon
isn't always out at night uh some and
most it's just an equal amount of time
it's out in broad daylight as it is out
at night so
so just just just saying so so a million
times larger so that is huge the sun has
blemishes which we call what
sunspots sunspots that's official
they're like liver spots except the sun
has really good skin
[Laughter]
okay
so the sun only occasionally has the
liver spots but has a really good
dermatologist this is what you're
telling me all right so the sun so
sunspots
are about the size of earth
so the sun has acne bigger than earth oh
my goodness
yeah yeah that's crazy that's that's
cold that's that's that's now sunspots
even though they're dark they have a lot
of high energy radiation so they'll go
off a lot of ultraviolet and even i
think some x-rays i'd have to double
check that
when the sunspot population grows
this we say the sun is active it's going
through its cycles
the sun it has an 11-year cycle
and it's
where there aren't many sunspots and
then there's a bunch of sunspots and
then there aren't many usually zero
actually and then it goes back to is it
more i don't know
i haven't asked actually no yes it is
more moody during sunspot yes yes
because during sunspots not not only is
the sun
radiate more
and this affects earth's atmosphere the
atmosphere absorbs this extra radiation
heats up
thickens
and all of our orbiting satellites now
have to boost themselves more back to
their orbit because it eats it it
encounters more atmospheric resistance
look at that
so that we do that with the space
station with the hubble telescope and
anybody else up there who wants to stay
and maintain an orbit a stable orbit
during solar max it's called we're on
the walk we're on the lookout for a
decay of our orbits because this the
atmosphere got thickened by this extra
radiation coming from the sun oh wow
that is really easy okay so that's one
moody thing it's it's messing with our
satellites okay that's one
sun blameable thing
what else happens is there are solar
flares
so explosions on the sun
and these explosions the sun is is a is
a is a magnetically charged gas right
and the word for that is plasma yeah
plasma yeah so
so the magnetic fields are all entangled
in there and during solar maximum the
magnetic fields become so entangled they
bust out
and when they bust out the particles of
the plasma like hanging on to that
magnetic field but they get flung
into space and then you get waves of
particles towards the earth there are
always waves of particles we call it the
solar wind
but during these particular moments
would you get a solar flare
oh my gosh this the the level of charged
particles can be so high it can
short-circuit the electronics of
satellites when it reaches earth wow
that's crazy
so yes the sun is moody at that time i'm
just making it clear okay and by the way
solar flares can happen but they don't
always point towards earth
we can see them but the pat the plasma
pie
goes out into space so it's the ones
where there's a solar flare
and it's headed towards earth that we
keep track of and in fact nasa has a
whole department called it's space
weather it's a space weather department
it's things that would affect astronauts
in space
and it's not only the sun it's also is
there's anything happening in the rest
of the galaxy so
that's so it's another thing that the
sun is doing oh one other thing go ahead
sunspots are always in pairs
okay i did not know this
and so chuck we measured it and one
would have a positive charge the other
negative charge so we got magnets on the
sun nice just saying all right but wait
there's more okay okay the sun is a big
ball of gas so it's not solid the way
earth is
and so
it turns out
the equator of the sun
completes one revolution faster than
other latitudes on the sun
so it doesn't rotate as a solid object
look at that because it's a big ball of
gas so the middle could be going faster
than the tops yes yes it's not that's
just to be clear it is always physically
going faster because it has more
distance to travel right so even if the
sun were solid it would be traveling
faster the way equatorial residents on
earth right they're all traveling a
thousand miles an hour we here in the
middle like new york latitudes are
traveling only about 800 miles an hour
due east because they we both complete a
circle at the same time
they went a bigger distance right so
they've got to be traveling faster okay
that's the merry-go-round effect the
outer horses are moving faster on the
merrier ground than the inner ones even
though it's moving as a solid rotating
as a solid object with the sun the
equator rotates faster now that here is
there's the rub so watch what happens
because the entire ball is magnetically
charged and their magnetic fields within
it the magnetic field wants to hold on
to the plasma and the rotating sun says
no you don't i'm going to stretch you
as i what we say differentially rotate
okay and as that happens the magnetic
fields stretch and stretch and stretch
and there's a point where they can no
longer
stay attached
and they snap
and this snapping is a very complicated
magnetohydrodynamical mechanism but the
disruption of the orderly magnetic
fields are what punches through to make
to make this the the flares on the
surface of the sun and when everybody
punches out and they get it out of the
system the magnetic fields reconnect and
we start the cycle again
oh oh but wait uh-oh but
it's not a oh that's not a oh okay but
wait okay oh by the way the sun has a
north pole and a south pole in addition
to all of this just so you know okay but
when the cycle repeats
the entire magnetic field of the sun has
flipped
oh snap so it's in fact a 22-year
complete cycle
not an 11-year cycle
yeah that is amazing that's the sun is
doing all that while you're sitting out
there you know on the beach while i'm
getting beautiful
it does all that and it makes me look
good too all right so let me i got to
quote galileo before we run out of time
here galileo said i'm i'm paraphrasing
because he said it more poetically than
i'm about to recount the sun
manages to keep the planets
in their appointed paths
yet somehow manages to ripen a bunch of
grapes
as though it had nothing else in the
world to do oh
that's
you know that galileo he knew how to
turn the phrase that's
and my boy was a wine drinker so that's
what he's talking about
i'm thinking about what else you do with
the grapes exactly
that's pretty good so that's all the sun
i could squeeze into 15 minutes here so
oh man that was fun chuck that's three
segments of stuff you thought you knew
yes are we calling it stuff or things
that's the same thing of course
things stuff is the same thing as things
they're both nouns who care
okay
so we're closing this out these are fun
we should do more of these i think and
yeah yeah so that's been star talk
stuff you thought you knew edition i'm
neil degrasse tyson as always chuck
thanks for being on uh neil degrasse
tyson signing off keep looking up
[Music]